if you could send one message to the
President of the United States about
your father what would it be if he could
please help my family the DNC is
underway and hundreds of protesters are
demanding an end to deportations
President Obama has deported over 2.5
million people more than any other US
president Adam ADIZ Lopez is 12 years
old she's a US citizen but her dad is
undocumented she watched him get taken
by ice last year on his way to work and
he's been in detention ever since like
almost every day I text the lawyer to
tell me what's going on and he calls my
mom and I don't really know how to talk
what do you swear do you text a lawyer
when you might win or message him or her
if he could come into me what's going on
the DNC is here this week and Hillary
Clinton is here what's your message sir
that we need her help in order to
accomplish a very bright future and I
feel like she can make America great
again unlike other people who were
actors and just want to learn her
president just 40 minutes away from
Philadelphia we have the birch Detention
Center which is one of many detention
centers that are basically family
prisons that are holding children
Adam Elise visits her dad once a month
in detention but she speaks to him
almost every day I will like to have my
dad back cuz he really hasn't done
anything bad here and all he does is
work
for his family and be with his family
and he doesn't deserve to be in there
you